he's the Commissioner of the National
Hockey League season stopped on March
12th the NHL will now move to a 2014
conference based postseason format that
was approved by the National Hockey
League Players Association last Friday
and the Commissioner joins us now
commissioner thank you for joining us
why did you think going into the
playoffs and that playoff format was the
right move well first of all I want to
know where I can buy that bobblehead of
you playing hockey and I think secondly
and more importantly thanks for having
me and I hope you and all your viewers
and listeners all your colleagues are
well and staying safe you know we have
extraordinary competitive balance our
regular season races to the playoffs go
down to the wires with lots of teams in
contention and if you look at the
standings as of March 12th and we took
the pause there were a lot of clubs on
the bubble and we thought it was only
fair since we couldn't complete the
regular season we were a hundred and
eighty nine games away from completing
the regular season that we had to give
those teams a chance that might very
well have made the playoffs if we had
been able to conclude the regular season
and instead of concluding the regular
season when we came back we were also
mindful of the fact that the players are
gonna have to be away from home and we
didn't want to have that experience to
be prolong any longer than really
necessary I saw we're about 17% of the
NHL our players from outside of North
America what's the biggest concern with
getting them into the state's tested and
you know just the safety precautions
well actually it's seven we have more
probably closer to 25% of our players
are from outside of North America but
17% of our players right now are in
locations outside in what North America
and we have to bring them back obviously
they're there our immigration issues
although since they all have valid visas
that shouldn't be an issue the bigger
issue is is the fact that they were
going to have to quarantine for a couple
of weeks and we're going to when we open
our training facility
which we hope to do the first week of
June they're going to be subject to some
testing as we move to the training camp
phase there'll be more testing and then
when we get to the actual playing test a
playing stage we're being told by our
medical people who were giving us all
the advice on this and whose advice
we're following players if they're not
being tested every day they're going to
be tested at least every other day but
is this the NHL doing the testing or
will it be individual teams doing the
testing well actually it'll be
individual teams in the training camp
and training facilities phase although
we have a backup for clubs that can
arrange to do it locally and any of the
tests we're doing whether it's the
club's the backup or what we're gonna do
when we're actually playing the
competition we're not going to do
anything that would interfere with the
medical needs that may be required for
testing and we're being told by the
experts that by the summer by the summer
there will be such an abundance of
testing our needs will really be
infinitesimal relative to what will be
available could the format of 24 teams
in the playoffs stay after this season
no what we like what we have our regular
season puts teams in the playoffs
virtually all season
we love the way the regular season plays
out it's every games meaningful are our
regular playoffs of 16 teams it's just
the right note the competition is the
entertainment value the excitement the
passion
couldn't be better and so we're doing
something extraordinary in response to
an extraordinary time fans in the stands
any possibility with them you know that
that's something we're not going to have
any control over of it if everything
we're doing is going to be subject to
the guidance and requirements of what
the medical people tell us and what the
governmental leaders are telling us at
all levels whether it's federal state or
a local and if they tell us we can have
fans and obviously nothing would make us
happier
and I think everybody should assume that
as we play this out over the summer and
into the fall it's probably most
unlikely that there'll be fans in the
building's not because we wouldn't want
them but it's safety it's a health issue
and we're listening to the experts I
know you have to look at the worst-case
scenario what if what if a player test
positive in the middle of the playoffs
then one
well we that's a question I've been
getting a lot for obvious reasons the
medical people are telling us one test
would require that player to be isolated
and you don't need an overreaction if
you have an outbreak that's a completely
different story what constitutes an
outbreak what procedures we need to
follow that is something that the
medical people are going to tell us
that's not a judgment that I'm gonna
make saying well just keep playing we'll
be doing what the Med with medical
people tell us is appropriate under the
circumstance how often do you consult
with government officials we're in
regular dialogue whether it's it's the
Prime Minister of Canada or some of his
ministers or the President of the United
States or governor's or premiers or
mayor's we're hearing from lots of them
in part because we want to get squared
away on the ability of getting players
in and out of the country and then we
have a lot of communities that are
lobbying to be one of the two hubs where
we're going to play this out now we as I
think people have heard have nine or ten
places under consideration all of which
we think can do this for us we're not
making a decision yet because we want to
do this in real time when we have to
because the information flow based on
the state of everything that's going on
is changing this isn't a decision in
terms of which location that I have to
make properly for another three to four
weeks at that point I'm gonna want to
see a what the state of kovat 19 is in
the communities we're considering
because obviously we reduce the risk of
any of our personal getting in fact that
if we're in place that has very little
Kovan the availability of testing and
the issues relative to moving personnel
across the border either to or from
Canada from the United States so that's
why we didn't want to put all of our
eggs in one basket we think it's better
to have a lot of options so that at the
time we have to make a decision we can
make the best decision possible talking
to the NHL commissioner Gary Bettman I
remember doing an interview with Pete
Rozelle David Stern Peter Ueberroth and
Larry Ziegler and at the time everybody
was commissioners he was the president
when did when did you become a
commissioner instead of the president of
the National Hockey League act actually
in addition to being president as
opposed to Commissioner I think his name
was John now John Ziegler but I think
that might be a golfer Larry Ziegler
when I was hired to come join the NHL
the view was there were lots of things
that needed to be done to modernize the
way the leap was operating at the time
and part of that was part of my
arrangement was I was going to be a
commissioner consistent with what the
other three major leagues were doing as
part of moving the league forward and my
powers got a little increased and it was
really to modernize the structure of how
we were conducting ourselves it sounds
more impressive though I think
Commissioner than president you know it
is what it is it's a word with you know
rose by any other name yes the best
piece of hockey memorabilia you have in
your house is one the best piece of well
I have my plaque from that's nice that's
that's pretty subjective I have before
my six before my 60th birthday I had by
that point my 65th birthday by that
point had presented the cup I don't know
over 20 times and a montage was made up
by Koli Campbell in the hockey
operations department of each of the
pictures of me doing that because the
best thing I get to do is present the
Stanley Cup I give you credit you
you're getting booed but you still love
taking that trophy out there when do I
get booed yeah you know as long as
they're not quiet it's a good thing
there's emotion is passion and hockey
fans are the best hey but you don't want
if you don't have fans this year
commissioner you won't get booed I'd
rather you know what we can pipe it in
how's that
we may do that Commissioner thank you
for joining us good luck with the
proposal in the format we appreciate
your time
thanks for having me I hope you your
family thank you that's the Commissioner
of the National Hockey League Gary
Bettman